ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu es descendu
sa joie sur l'emploi révélé nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du mammouth je
me trouvera à fouiller en sibérie et
puis un beau matin dans le trou que
j'avais commencé à creuser je trouve de
lait tout comme c'est quelque chose de
billard des grands filaments je suis
étonnée je râle je dirais que ce sont
des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche
et puis à force de tirer dessus comme
rien ne venait je me suis aperçu que
j'étais sur le dos
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
le vario mikron continue sa propagation
qu'il est jugé très contagieux pelo oms
indique cependant n'avoir aucune
information concernant d'éventuels décès
en france c'est le variant delta qui
seraient responsables de la flambée des
contaminations le gouvernement va-t-il
annoncer de nouvelles restrictions un
conseil de défense sanitaire aura lieu
lundi
[Musique]
c'est une commande record pour la france
les émirats arabes unis souhaitent
acquérir 80 avions de combat rafale le
contrat a été signé dans la journée à
l'occasion de la visite à dubaï
d'emmanuel macron une honte et un
scandale dénonçant l'opposition de
gauche
[Musique]
et puis nous reviendrons sur le sommet
de l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe philips et est
achevée ce vendredi à stockholm deux
jours des changes entre les ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'osce 6e sur
fond de vives tensions autour de
l'ukraine
le kremlin confirme que vladimir poutine
et joe biden devrait s'entretenir
prochainement
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
on ignore encore la dangerosité du
variant omicron aucune information selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
concernant d'éventuelles la décès le
gouvernement reste en alerte sept cas
ont été identifiés en france
métropolitaine les chiffres de
l'épidémie sont à la hausse la situation
préoccupante à l'hôpital de nouvelles
mesures ont déjà été prises et d'autres
restrictions pourraient être annoncées
dont la foulée d'un nouveau conseil de
défense sanitaire
l'indicé réel bouées et françois tessier
beach
plusieurs cas omicron confirmé dans
l'hexagone ce jeudi
des cas qui pourraient se multiplier
très rapidement selon le temps de parole
du gouvernement ne soyons donc ni dupe
ni naïf il y aura très probablement des
cas sur notre territoire dans les
prochaines heures ou les prochains jours
qui seront détectés conséquence le
gouvernement a décidé de durcir les
conditions d'entrée sur le territoire
désormais tout voyageur même vacciné en
provenance d'un pays hors de l'union
européenne doit disposer d'un test pcr
négatif durcissement aussi dans certains
hôpitaux où le plan blanc a été
déclenché notamment à colmar strasbourg
ou encore roman ce dispositif permet de
reporter certaines opérations afin de se
concentrer principalement sur les cathos
vide du point de vue médical ce que je
peux dire c'est que quand on voit les
vidéos qui circulent
sur les réseaux on voit bien que la
distance et son physique n'est pas
respectée que les gens n'ont pas de deux
masques même en dehors de moments oui
imanche donc bien évidemment ça nous
inquiète beaucoup on est dans une
société où en gros il ya beaucoup
d'individualisme font remettre du sens
commun remettent aussi du collectif et
de la solidarité entre les générations
entre les gens et est vraiment con con
qu'on aille tous dans le même sens pour
essayer de s'en sortir à paris certains
hôpitaux saturent déjà face à la forte
augmentation des patients dans les
services de réanimation
depuis 48 heures il ya des patients
qu'on ne peut pas prendre parce que les
réanimations son plein on a une vraie
sensation de déjà vécu mais
malheureusement les règles n'ont pas
changé unsa mba qui se fait donc sentir
sur le territoire le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy s' appelle à davantage
d'attention afin de sauver les fêtes de
fin d'année pour les vacances de noël le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent assure ne rien pouvoir promettre
mais restent optimistes quant à leur bon
déroulement
et les autorités ne cessent d'appeler
chalain vaccination elle sera ouverte
aux enfants de 5 à 11 ans risquant de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
et ouverte vers l'ami voir la fin
décembre c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
ministre de la santé avant d'être
élargie saut avant d'être sans doute
élargie à l'ensemble des enfants début
janvier progressivement et de façon
facultative précise olivier vers en
cette cinquième vague touche toute
l'europe fait en riposte les mesures
prises sont plus ou moins sévères
l'allemagne elle décide de serrer la vis
elle s'apprête à interdire aux non
vaccinés l'accès aux commerces d'un
essentiel restaurants lieux de culture
ou de loisirs et dans la salle
c'est la dernière de son long parcours
de chancelière allemande angela merkel a
tenu une conférence de presse en
compagnie de son successeur
olaf scholz elle a détaillé les mesures
qui entrent en vigueur dès aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre la propagation du
virus kobe de 19 en allemagne
nous allons réserver dans toute
l'allemagne l'accès aux infrastructures
et aux événements de la culture et des
loisirs indépendamment de l'incidence
uniquement aux personnes vaccinées guéri
il est également possible de faire un
test complémentaires selon si la
personne d'actionner guéri a testé les
règles de gvt ac signer aux guerriers
sont également étendus au commerce de
détail sauf pour les magasins de
consommation courante et eglin d'autres
nouvelles restrictions vont également
touché l'ensemble de la population
allemande la fréquentation des grands
rassemblements comme les matches de
football de la bundesliga devra être
plafonnées à 30% de la capacité
d'accueil totale les clubs et boîtes de
nuit vont à nouveau fermées dans les
zones où le taux d'incidence
hebdomadaire dépasse 350 soit 9 régions
sur cèze y compris la capitale par
ailleurs le port du masque redevient
obligatoire dans les établissements
scolaires du pays
ce durcissement des restriction
intervient alors que la vaccination
obligatoire est en cours de discussion
au parlement
je suis heureux que le bundestag
allemand et commencer à délibérer et à
discuter de l'introduction d'une
obligation de vaccination pour les
institutions dans lesquelles les
citoyennes et les citoyens
particulièrement sensibles doivent être
protégés comme les établissements de
soins et les hôpitaux nous aurons aussi
un vote ouverts au bundestag sur une
obligation générale de vaccination je
pense que les choses vont avancer et je
suis confiant que le bundestag prendra
une telle décision
mercredi soir à munich le mouvement
antivaccin c-vert denken organisé une
manifestation pour protester contre ces
nouvelles mesures elle a donné lieu à
quelques échanges houleux avec les
forces de l'ordre près de 70 % des
allemands et 80 % des adultes sont
aujourd'hui vacciner avant la réunion de
cet après midi le ministre sortant de la
santé oms panne avait qualifié le
dispositif à venir de confinement pour
ainsi dire des personnes non vaccinées
avec l'apparition du variant omicron un
vent de panique a soufflé partout dans
le monde certains pays décidant de
fermer leurs frontières elle c'est le
cas du japon avant qu'il ne se rétracte
le gouvernement nippon est partiellement
revenue sur sa demande aux compagnies
aériennes de suspendre les nouvelles
réservations à destination du pays afin
que ces ressortissants puissent rentrer
chez eux hélène masquelier
vols annulés les panneaux d'affichage de
l'aéroport narita traduisent la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement
nippon le japon a voulu se barricader
face aux variants omicron mais peut-être
un peu trop vite et un peu trop fort ce
mercredi le premier ministre a annoncé
la suspension de toutes les nouvelles
réservations à destination de l'archipel
jusqu'à la fin du mois de décembre
une mesure jugée trop stricte par la
population
je vis au japon depuis deux ans depuis
le début du coc vide je pense que le
japon a été de loin le pays le plus
strict en ce qui concerne l'épidémie et
l'interdiction des étrangers explique
encore une fois à quel point le japon se
montre stricte en général nv nord sous
pression le gouvernement est revenu ce
jeudi sur sa décision pour permettre aux
ressortissants japonais de rentrée
al'approche de noël
voilà social ronny heer et demandé au
ministre des transports de prêter
pleinement attention aux besoins des
citoyens japonais qui souhaitent rentrer
chez eux ap new tango lauder une mesure
qui restent strictes avec une limite
imposée à 3500 arrivées internationales
par jour contre 5000 auparavant une
décision que le gouvernement japonais a
préféré à d'autres mesures pour endiguer
l'épidémie la campagne de vaccination
reste lente dans le pays et les centres
commence à être démantelé
en ce qui concerne les injection de
rappel le ministère de la défense non
visage pas d'utiliser ce centre pour le
moment au moment de notre combat contre
le coronavirus ni compris le variant au
bic phone n'est pas encore terminée nous
devons nous y préparer
le japon a été relativement épargné par
la pandémie avec près de 18 mille morts
depuis début 2000 20 confiné l'archipel
entier pour ne pas confiner les
habitants une stratégie propre au
gouvernement nippon et qui semble payer
il aura fallu treize ans de négociations
la france vont 80 rafale aux émirats
arabes unis cela représente 17 milliards
d'euros pour l'ensemble du contrat le
plus important passé par dassault
aviation l'avion de combat est désormais
vendu dans six pays en comptant les
gippsland le qatar la grèce et la
croatie l'accord a été signé au cours de
la visite des manuels macron à dubaï
première étape du chef de l'état avant
le 14 et l'arabie saoudite
le partenariat stratégique auquel nous
donnons plus de force et de contenus
avec les émirats arabes unis il suit cet
agenda paix et stabilité dans la région
lutte contre tous les extrêmes lutte
contre le terrorisme et coopération très
concrètes sur les situations sensibles
c'est le plus gros contrat militaire à
composante française de notre histoire
c'est avec le signant là et cette vente
fait grincer des dents comme l'ensemble
du voyage à des manuels macron émirats
arabes unis et arabie saoudite sont
impliqués dans le conflit au yémen la
pire crise humanitaire au monde selon
l'onu de quoi faire à bondir
l'opposition de gauche écoutez sa
réaction
la france nous fait honte quand l arme
des régimes autoritaires qui méprise les
droits humains et dont la richesse s'est
bâtie sur les énergies fossiles la
france rayonne racan sa politique
étrangère sera exemplaire dans la lutte
pour la liberté et la justice climatique
dans une démocratie les ventes d'armes
ne devrait pas échapper au contrôle
politique à quand une politique
européenne des exportations d'armes
contrat de vente historique pour 80
rafale vraiment pas de quoi être fier
c'est scandaleux mais à l'image d'un
capitalisme militariste affairistes et
cynique faut interdire la vente d'armes
et distribue à la place médicaments et
vaccins pour les populations des pays du
sud
visite des manuels maquereau en arabie
saoudite dont le ministre libanais de
l'information a dit vouloir profiter
pour annoncer sa démission il espère en
cire et des le liban georges kordahi
avait critiqué l'intervention de ryad
dans la guerre au yémen provoquant une
grave crise diplomatique avec les états
du golfe des propos tenus avant sa
nomination est révélé il y a quelques
semaines conduisant que l'arabie
saoudite a rappelé son ambassadeur à
beyrouth et a expulsé l'ambassadeur
libanais bahreïn les émirats arabes unis
et le koweït avait également pris des
mesures de rétorsion à l'égard du liban
face à la presse le désormais ancien
ministre libanais a expliqué sa décision
en parlant avec le premier ministre
najib mikati que j'ai rencontré il y a
trois jours j'ai compris que les
français veulent ma démission avant la
visite officielle du président français
emmanuel macron à ryad
cela peut sans doute aidé à améliorer le
dialogue avec les autorités saoudiennes
à propos du liban ainsi que les
relations entre beyrouth et ryad
camille australie on part maintenant en
italie l'italie qui devrait bientôt
extradées un tunisien présumés membres
de l'organisation terroriste dèche vers
la tunisie l'homme âgé de 25 ans et qui
fait l'objet d'un mandat d'arrêt
international émis par un tribunal de
tunis avait déposé une demande d'asile
auprès des autorités italiennes le point
avec notre correspondant en tunisie
bassam chebbi
le voyage aura été de courte durée pour
ce citoyen tunisien membres présumés de
l'organisation terroriste dahesh état
islamique interpellés par l'unité des
enquêtes générales et des opérations
spéciales de la police de venise le
jeune homme de 25 ans avait débarqué
illégalement sur l'île italienne de
lampedusa le 12 septembre dernier elle
vit à un bateau de migrants inscrit sous
une fausse identité il avait été
transféré dans un autre centre d'accueil
à venise selon les autorités italiennes
le service de coopération policière
internationale avait entre-temps informé
la direction centrale de la police
italienne que les autorités tunisiennes
avaient signalé la probable présence en
italie d'un de leurs citoyens liés à
l'organisation terroriste état islamique
avant d'annoncer que la justice
tunisienne avait émis un mandat d'amener
à son encontre selon les premiers
éléments de l'enquète l italie n'était
pas la destination finale du présumé
terroriste qui visait plutôt le nord de
l'europe et aucune activités liées à la
préparation d'un attentat n'avait été
est découverte l'individu sera extradé
vers la tunisie dans les prochains jours
et devra comparaître devant la justice
tunisienne
le kremlin confirme que vladimir poutine
et joe biden devrait s'entretenir
prochainement c'est l'un des points
saillants pour l issue du sommet de
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe il s'est tenu
pendant deux jours à stockholm sur fond
de tensions entre les etats-unis et la
russie autour de l'ukraine ont fait le
bilan de cette réunion des ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'osce 6e avec
notre envoyé spécial en suède david
khalifa
un bilan plutôt mitigé pour ce 28e
beating de l'eau scee et qui est censé
prôné le multilatéralisme et la pêche
finalement ce meeting a été le théâtre
de règlements de comptes entre les pays
membres elle cela a permis pour de
nombreux pays d'exprimer ses
remontrances sur le plan international
ce qui est révélateur d'une
multiplication de tension au marche de
l'europe la présidence suédoise n'a
d'ailleurs pas manqué de le rappeler
lors de l'ultime conférence de presse
certains états ont fait passer leurs
intérêts nationaux aux dépens des
intérêts internationaux selon ses mots
en témoigne la passe d'armes entre le
maroc et l'algérie aujourd'hui sur les
frontières la russie a principalement
été visé également un durant ce meeting
accusée de déstabiliser la sûreté
européennes à la frontière ukrainienne
écouter la présidente de l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'osce à notre micro
je pense que cela montre l'importance de
l'eau et steve lowe et cae a été fondée
pendant la guerre froide nous avons
également une augmentation du niveau
d'insécurité très étroitement lié à la
russie au comportement de la russie je
pense qu'il est important que les
ministres des affaires étrangères se
rencontrent je pense qu'il est important
d'avoir ces rencontres qui offre un
espace de dialogue je pense que les
rencontres en personne sont importantes
notamment les rencontres bilatérales
entre ministres des affaires étrangères
parce que nous avons besoin bien sûr de
paix de sécurité de respect de
l'intégrité nationale je le dis en tant
que parlementaire en tant qu'élus et
parlementaires parce que nous
travaillons pour le peuple et le peuple
nous a confié la tâche de soutenir la
consolidation de la paix de défendre les
droits de leurs pays et c'est ce à quoi
je vends des reit de la can cette date
ouattara et pourtant ce ariella bros n'a
cessé de répéter durant toute la journée
a dit hier que la russie n'avait pas
l'intention d'envahir à l'ukraine le
chef de la diplomatie russe souhaite une
solution dans le cadre d'un dialogue
avec les états unis et leurs alliés
c'est ce dont il a été question durant
sa réunion avec anthony blinken est la
première depuis la prise de pouvoir de
joe biden s ariel abreuve déplore
l'agressivité occidentale et accusent
l'otan d'être sourd aux propositions de
paires russes il espère que löw et ce
pour a changé la donne en ce sens joe
biden et vladimir poutine devrait
d'ailleurs s'entretenir sur cette
question est ici est les prochains jours
ormis à la crise migratoire à la
frontière polonaise a longuement été
évoquée également j'ai pu interroger le
nouveau président de l'otc e pour
l'année 2022 chef de la diplomatie
polonaise et donc à directement
concernés par cette question a notamment
sur le traitement des journalistes à la
frontière puisque certains d'entre eux
comme moi ont été arrêtés écouter
les deux valeurs entrent donc ici en
compétition la liberté de la presse et
la liberté de recueillir des
informations selon le mode que le
journaliste considère le plus approprié
et la garantie de la sécurité
frontalière y compris la sécurité de
ceux qui protègent la frontière ces
soldats agents de sécurité
il ne fait aucun doute qu'il y ait un
conflit de deux valeurs majeures pour
tout état démocratique la liberté de la
presse des médias contre la sécurité
d'une frontière qui étaient prises
d'assaut par un état voisin
c'était une solution regrettable mais
absolument nécessaire pour des raisons
de sécurité y compris celle des citoyens
qui vivent sur place et était soumis à
cet assaut constant de l'état voisin
[Musique]
une explication en déca des principes
mêmes de l'union européenne mais assez
révélatrice des divers discours qu'on a
pu entendre durant ces deux derniers
jours à l'eau et ce à des discours pavé
de bonnes intentions mais avec peu de
concret finalement
confit d'intérêt trafic d'influencé au
sommet de l'union européenne dans une
enquête publiée cette semaine le
quotidien libération révèle de graves
dysfonctionnements au sein des
institutions communautaires un système
qui impliquerait pour l'essentiel des
membres du parti populaire européen les
détails avec nadège abderrazak
1000 milliards d'euros ce serait le coût
annuel de la corruption au sein de
l'union européenne corruption à présente
jusque dans les plus hautes sphères des
institutions européennes dans une
enquête de libération
on apprend que certains hauts
responsables de la cour des comptes
européenne abuse tous azimuts prime de
logement exorbitantes pour domicile
fictif notes de frais non contrôlés
absences injustifiées mission non
vérifié un comble pour un organe censé
surveiller le bon usage des deniers
publics européenne 27 membres de la cce
sont obligés de vivre en permanence dans
le grand duché ou à la frontière
exactement comme les membres de la
commission doivent habiter à bruxelles
c'est là que doit se trouver le centre
de leurs intérêts familiaux ils
reçoivent pour ce faire une indemnité de
logement mensuelle de 15 % de leur
salaire 22000 430 euros 24000 pour le
président soit une prime comprise entre
3364 et 3600 euros à cela s'ajoute un
pécule de cas entre mille euros pour les
frais de déménagement et d'installation
le président justement c'est klaus à 1h
laine un ancien député européen allemand
proche de la cd ou dans gala merkel un
appartement figure à son nom au
luxembourg mais l'âme ne viendrait sur
place que pour les réunions où sa
présence est obligatoire soit un à deux
jours par mois environ la plupart du
temps il résiderait en allemagne dans la
ville de düsseldorf depuis sa prise de
fonction à la tête de la cour des
comptes européenne
il aurait ainsi empoché plus de 325 1000
euros pour ces seuls frais de logement
325 1000 euros en guise d'appel aide
personnalisée au logement quelque sorte
tout ça pour ne pas habiter dans ledit
logement c'est loin d'être le seul un
tiers des membres de l'institution
n'habiteraient pas à luxembourg peut-on
donc logiquement par les deux frotte pas
pour le principal intéressé
la plupart des allégations portées dans
l'article publié par libération sont
fausses les déclarations sont non
fondées et non véridiques comme
l'appartement mesure 160 m² j'en ai sous
louer une partie où et avec qui je vis
au luxembourg relève de mes affaires
privées nous sommes en train de décider
s'il est judicieux de porter l affaire
en justice ou non klaus einer l'aisne
s'est aussi dit prêt à fournir des
documents à deux membres de la
commission de contrôle budgétaire mais
tenez vous bien se refuse à soumettre la
cour en audit indépendant à raison
invoquée par ce contrôleur en chef ne
souhaitant pas être contrôlé cela
donnerait une mauvaise image de la cour
des comptes européenne et affecterait sa
crédibilité comme si cette cour n'était
pas déjà mise à mal par les révélations
de libération et le quotidien ne
s'arrête pas là conflits d'intérêts
flagrants pressions politiques
appartement fictifs dans un second volet
le pointe du doigt l'ensemble des
institutions européennes journal rai le
réseau de trafic d'influencé dominé par
le ppf le parti populaire européen et
qui regroupe un ensemble de partis de
droite et constituent la première force
politique de l'union européenne
depuis qu angela merkel a été élu à la
chancellerie en 2005 elle a placé ses
hommes à tous les niveaux de pouvoir
beaucoup d'allemands mais aussi des gens
de pays proches de l'allemagne
finlandais néerlandais flamand
autrichien et c'est ces gens
fonctionnent entre eux ils vivent dans
une bulle et la facilité des moyens qui
leur sont octroyés et de l'utilisation
de ces moyens leur fait perdre toute
éthique quant à l'utilisation de ce
pouvoir c'est cela que je démonte c'est
un état ppe qui vérole l'union
européenne des révélations qui
pourraient poser quelques problèmes à
quelques semaines du début de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
emmanuel macron acompte a sûrement sur
cette vitrine pour briller sur l'échelle
européenne à des fins électoralistes
puisque l'élection présidentielle
française a lieu en effet dans moins de
cinq mois une vitrine qui aujourd'hui en
dépit de la proximité de noël est loin
de briller de mille feux
un retour en france l'espoir d'un retour
au calme en guadeloupe foule il est
touché depuis deux semaines par de
violentes protestations alors que les
barrages routiers et commence à être
démantelé les élus s'inquiètent
toutefois de l'évolution de la situation
et cherchent une sortie de crise malgré
l'échec des dernières négociations avec
les syndicats les précisions sur place
de l'hiver sepric a
deux semaines après l appel à la
mobilisation là prix social perdu ici en
guadeloupe le couvre-feu a été prolongé
par le préfet alexandre rochatte
jusqu'au 7 décembre dans 21 communes
sous les 32 que compte l'archipel de
nouveau à ce coup ci ont été dégagés par
les forces de l'ordre toutefois
certaines voix principale reste rude
même bloqué comme à perrin aux abymes ou
encore à la boucan à sainte-rose
concernant les écoles et le ouf petit à
petit dès que les conditions d'accès et
de sécurité sont win quelques jours
après l'échec des négociations avec le
ministre d outre mer les élus locaux et
les syndicats se sont réunis afin
d'enclencher une sortie de crise le
message est le même la mise en place
d'un accord de méthode permettant les
négociations entre les parties
impliquées dans ce conflit semble
aujourd'hui plus que nécessaire ils
demandent également la venue d'une
délégation interministérielle qui
permettrait dans les plus brefs délais
des traités les revendications qui
relève de l'état comme l'a déclaré elie
domota porte parole du lkp contrairement
à ce que monsieur le cornu a dit la
quasi totalité des points de
revendications qui sont dans le
protocole relève également de
l'intervention de l'état et de l'état au
plus haut niveau il ne peut pas y avoir
de négociations s'il n'y a pas de
véritable protocole d'accord sur la
méthode de négociation avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes en l'occurrence la
délégation interministérielle que l'état
prenne ses responsabilités
reste à savoir quelle sera la réponse de
paris suite à ce premier pas dans les
discussions entre syndicats et
politiques locaux
il avait tenu des propos jugés
diffamatoires sur twitter fin 2018
conduisant rt france a porté plainte
nicolas tenzer a été relaxé la cour a
estimé qu il n'exprimait que des
jugements de valeur ou des opinions ces
accusations de procédures bayo et
d'intimidation ont en revanche été
rejetées par les juges il a ainsi été
débouté de ses demandes de condamner
notre chaîne à payer les dommages et
intérêts pour procédure abusive ainsi
que ses frais de procédure arte france
va faire appel du jugement elle
considère que les propos de nicolas
tenzer porte atteinte à la réputation et
à l'honneur de la chaîne
c'est extrêmement décevant mais
malheureusement pas surprenant puisque
depuis kert existe elle subit un
traitement totalement différent voire
discriminatoire par rapport à tous les
autres médias
on lui refuse l'accès à la salle de
presse de l'elysée dès qu'elle se
constitue partie civile dans à la suite
de propos qui sont gravement
diffamatoires le les juridictions et les
tribunaux pour l'instant pas encore la
cour d'appel mais que les tribunaux
relaxes systématiquement les personnes
poursuivies est vraiment deux poids deux
mesures vous avez la jurisprudence et
les règles de droit qui s'applique pour
tous les médias puis vous avez une
application qui est différente
si vous êtes certes et nous allons
interjeter appel
j'ai encore l'espoir que les magistrats
de la cour d'appel de paris
reprennent et applique les jurisprudence
habituelle en matière de diffamation et
ne
confère pas un statut différent et des
lois et des joueuses ans différentes
suivant le média que vous représentez rt
respecte toutes les législations en
vigueur dans chacun des pays dans
lesquels elle émet notamment en france
il n'y a pas de raison qu'un bénéficient
pas de la protection
inhérentes à la situation française
et c'est la fin de cette édition on se
retrouve avant des meneurs pour un
nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
j'appelle en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche prg
extrêmement musée la menace de citer un
deuxième jeu
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
la hausse des prix du gaz l'électricité
touche directement au moins 36 millions
d'européens pour la france plus question
de fermer 14 réacteurs pourraient nuire
à 50% la part du nucléaire 2035
l'allemagne est dans une toute autre
logique devenu club by gaz russe en
europe elle